sam coates report does contain some
flashing images
a conservative winner like no other in
four decades
always an unconventional path which took
him to the heart of the establishment
proving doubters wrong with an 80-seat
majority tory mps were told time and
again to trust him through the
turbulence holidays and wallpaper but
who paid for what upending the rules for
an mp found guilty of sleaze parties in
downing street and the denials that
followed
but dealing with brexit the pandemic the
cost of living crisis and war in ukraine
never allowed a moment for politics as
normal
[Music]
all the time gradually the public were
changing their mind
now tory mps have threatened him a life
ring a win yes but far from settling
manners has it just exposed divisions
veterans of past story leadership
challenges clear there's trouble ahead
what we have seen today is a classic
example of a party where its fractures
become very very open
between the members of parliament as
they're looking for their own particular
constituency so it's a big deal and it
can't be underestimated and boris
johnson is going to be damaged there's
no two ways about it
all this barely three years on from the
last attempt to ouster pm
the parliamentary party
does have confidence
[Applause]
theresa may survived on the day but was
gone within six months but with enormous
and enduring gratitude
to have had the opportunity
to serve the country i love
history suggests vote like today is
rarely settled matters
was never the same again and mark
thatcher fell on her sword
uh and theresa may uh was
uh faithfully wounded it's a vote in
time but uh but a lot of things happen
very quickly
for a
prime minister who has the skates under
them
this is the messiest of all outcomes for
boris johnson cabinet ministers in
public saying a win is a win but in
private insiders quite open that the
poor showing tonight is going to make
their life more difficult
and now what if the tories lose both
by-elections in a few weeks time or if
mps judge that boris johnson lied to the
commons
right now the conservative party seems
on balance determined to place its faith
in a man who delivered their landslide
barely three years ago
sam coates sky news westminster